foreign
this the junk drawer challenge so good
man or as Ryan would say the drunk
drawer the drunk George
this is how to eliminate the junk in
your junk drawer today
shout out to one of our patreon
subscribers Kate who sent us this Tick
Tock video Professor would you play that
for us this used to be the junk drawer
and he cleaned it all out and he put
everything in this box and he's telling
me that unless I can name stuff that's
in there that I want to out
he's getting rid of it all
and the only thing I can think of right
now is my twist ties which I'm the twist
ties are coming out of the box you got
that that's it's your own prize where's
the scissor or the scissors scissors all
right that's two you want to throw away
you're gonna throw everything out though
like you don't need anything what about
things that you need it's all junk
it's not all junk junk drawer some of it
we've probably needed
no you're gonna start the shower you go
I go to people's houses take everything
out and they got something that was in
their house to get it back
otherwise it means otherwise it's
garbage but they didn't need it yeah I
hope they remember their kid's name it's
so good that's Genie I showed this to
Mariah I was like will you please do
this with my stuff
this is a packing party for your junk
drawer but you're doing it for someone
else now I want to be clear I would
never encourage anyone to go take their
partner stuff so what we have here in
this video if you just listen to the
audio version of the podcast what we
have here is a husband and wife couple
and the husband has packed up everything
in their Collective junk drawer which
often turns into junk drawers when we
were doing Ryan's packing party he had
seven junk drawers and it's because one
junk drawer fills up and instead of
dealing with it well I've got another
drawer here I can just turn that into a
junk drawer number two number three etc
etc and so what happens is we have a
bunch of stuff and we don't remember
what was in there and I love what she
said there because it exposes exactly
our psychology that leads to the excess
there are probably some things that I
need in there well she didn't even say
there are things that we think
we will need so it's it's like it's this
um uh the 2020 rule it's it is this rule
of we hold on to all these just in case
items and they usually end up in the
drunk drawer yeah so the minimalist rule
book you can download it for free at the
minimalists.com 16 rules for living with
less one of those is the just in case
rule or the 2020 rule I think you
combine that with Ryan's packing party
and then you combine it with something
new that we called the didn't know rule
like I didn't even know I owned this
almost everything in her junk drawer she
didn't realize she owned yeah you know
like I said don't do this to someone
else without their permission but I love
that you went to Mariah and said hey can
you do this with our junk drawer because
if you don't remember that it's in there
you can give yourself permission to let
it go did you enjoy this Standalone
patreon highlight if so you can listen
to full episodes of the minimalist
private podcast available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free